Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, die 2. Männer Bundesliga. Sie hat ihren letzten Spieltag hinter sich. Für 17, nein für 16 der 18 Mannschaften ist die Saison vorbei. Darüber wollen wir sprechen jetzt hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 204. Hallo, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Ihr seid wahrscheinlich auch noch elektrisiert von diesem Saison Finale in der 2. Männer Bundesliga. So geht es uns auch. Und deshalb wollen wir das jetzt aufarbeiten. In der Runde der emotional direkt Beteiligten. Deswegen begrüße ich bei mir und frage sie, ob sie ihre Stimme wiedergefunden hat. Sina vom Weserfunk, die Ed, Sina, Sophie, auf Twitter. Hallo, Sina.
Und nein, sie ist noch sehr verschollen. Ich hoffe, ich finde sie im Laufe des Tages wieder.
Aber man hört die Endorphine quasi durch diese raue Stimme. Das ist doch auch schön. Geht es dir? Ich nehme an, es geht dir gut.
Ich glaube, dass sie insgesamt fand ich den Eindruck, dass es eine sehr emotionale Saison war. Mag an der Rückkehr der Fans auch gelegen haben, dass das so mit reinspielt, aber ich hatte irgendwie immer so das Gefühl eines Etnisterns auch dann durch den engen Aufstiegskampf und so weiter. Das ist halt das, glaube ich, was hängen bleibt. Es war einfach so viel drin und so viel Emotionen mit drin, dass es eine Gänsehautsaison letztlich war. Ich denke auch für Darmstadt, Werder, Schalke sowieso gilt das wahrscheinlich auch. Ich glaube, selbst der Stadtteil nebenan ist durchaus mitgenommen. Ja, letztlich werden sie zufrieden sein mit Platz 5. Das haben sie vor der Saison nicht unbedingt mitgerechnet.
Sina, für dich war es ja die erste Zweitligasaison, so als direkte Beteiligte. Zumindest seit ganz langem. Nee, doch müsste die erste gewesen sein. So alt kannst du nicht sein. Sorry, ich wollte jetzt gar nicht über dein Alter spekulieren. Aber wie hast du denn diese Saison erlebt? Die Frage wollte ich eigentlich stellen. Hätte ich sie doch einfach gestellt.
Also, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, es war schon irgendwie schön. Ich meine, ich habe jetzt nicht irgendwie die utopische Vorstellung, dass wir jetzt ganz oben mitspielen in der ersten Liga. Das wird vielleicht auch jetzt so unser Schicksal sein, dass wir vielleicht erstmal wieder zur Fahrschulmannschaft werden. Man weiß es ja nicht. Aber gerade so mit der Rückkehr ins Stadion. Ich habe die letzten Ausweisfahrten jetzt auch alle mitgenommen. Ich habe den Nudeltopf in Aue gegessen. Absolutes Highlight. Nicht kulinarisch, aber fürs Gefühl. Schalke war schön. Gut, das haben wir in der ersten Liga auch häufig gehabt. Aber ich war vorher auch noch nie auf St. Pauli. Das war auch echt cool. Natürlich konnte man nicht alles mitnehmen, aber auch einfach mal wieder gewinnen und dieses Gefühl. Auch von Bedeutung zu sein in der Liga und nicht irgendwo unten oder im Mittelfeld rumzudümpeln, das war schon echt ganz nett. Man muss auch ehrlich sagen, diese Saison war die zweite Liga einfach interessanter. Klar, man hat da jetzt die eigene Perspektive, aber die Bayern sind wieder Meister geworden. Abstiegskampf in der ersten Liga, okay, war jetzt echt nochmal spannend. Aber was sagt das denn darüber aus, dass das Spannendste einer Liga wirklich der Abstiegskampf ist? Ich habe die jetzt wirklich gerne mitgenommen. Das Ding ist halt immer, dass man im Hinterkopf hat, da hängen Jobs dran, da gibt es viel weniger Geld. Deswegen ist man jetzt auch einfach froh, wieder oben zu sein und dann auch wirklich sagen zu können, erst Klassik. Da gehören wir hin eigentlich. Hoffentlich wird es dann einfach die nächsten Jahre immer wieder spannender. Es war emotional extrem, gerade durch die viele Zeit ohne Stadion und ohne Fans. Ich finde, man hat gerade in den letzten Wochen wirklich extrem gemerkt, was Fußball ohne Fans eigentlich ist. Nämlich gar nichts. Ob das jetzt Frankfurt ist, ob das auch der FC ist oder Werder, HSV, das ist so ein Unterschied. Und es tat so gut, das einfach wieder ausleben zu können und wirklich wieder Fan sein zu können und nicht nur von zu Hause alles beobachten zu können. Das war einfach eine Achterbahn.
Ja, und wer weiß, also der letzte Aufstieg war ja 1980, 1981, damals mit dem neuen Trainer Otto Rehagel. Und der sollte ja dann doch noch eine ganz gute Karriere bei Werder machen. Vielleicht kann ja Ole Wanner da eine kleine Parallele ziehen. Wie schön ich da jetzt gerade Druck aufgebaut habe. Mir fällt es immerhin selbst noch auf. Und darüber hinaus, was wird bei dir hängen bleiben, Matthias? Für Darmstadt war es jetzt die fünfte Zweitligasaison in Folge, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Das heißt, du bist der Zweitliga-Veteran. Da musst du uns ja eigentlich erzählen. Was war denn anders in dieser Saison? Diese ganzen jungen Neuen, die da reingekommen sind und für Wirbel gesorgt haben. Haben sie dich genervt?
Ja, ich fand es zu Beginn der Saison ein bisschen nervig, weil es wird ja schon seit Jahrzehnten von der besten Saison oder besten Zweitligasaison aller Zeiten gesprochen. Dieses Jahr konnte man das Label wohl mit einiger Berechtigung aufkleben. Gleichwohl wurde dann von den üblichen Verdächtigen gesprochen. Also die drei, die jetzt vorne sind, wurden genannt. Dann musste man schon ein bisschen suchen, vielleicht noch mit Abstrichen Nürnberg oder Düsseldorf oder St. Pauli. Aber die Zweitligaklubs, die die zweite Liga ausmachen, die wurden gar nicht genannt. Also KSC oder auch wir. Und wie du sagst, wir spielen jetzt zum fünften Mal in Folge in der Zweitligada vor zwei Erstligaspielzeiten, davor der Durchmarsch. Also auch eine Zweitligaspielzeit. Wir gehören eigentlich seit acht Jahren, wenn man so will. Waren wir zweimal Zehntal der Zwo-Liga. Ansonsten immer zu den Top-25-Clubs. Aber Darmstadt taucht irgendwie gar nicht auf in der allgemeinen Erzählung. Dabei sind wir auch in der ewigen Tabelle der Zwo-Liga, mittlerweile Siebter. Also das ist schon krass so gewesen, dass wir in der heißen Phase des kommerziellen Fußballs leider abgehängt waren. Also da waren wir Dritt- und Viertligist und deshalb sind wir gerade auch bei den jungen Fans wahrscheinlich einfach nicht präsent oder irgendwie so ein Underdog. Aber ich denke, wir haben das Label Zwo-Ligist nicht zu unrecht und beweisen das Spielzeit für Spielzeit. Wenn man betrachtet, wo wir vor zehn Jahren standen, dann ist das schon vor 15 und 20 erst recht bemerkenswert. Und deshalb mache ich da so ein gewisses von der ersten Liga her kommendes –ja, oder wie soll ich sagen? Also die erste Liga dominiert durchaus viel und strahlt auf die zweite Liga ab. Und wenn große Klubs runterkommen, weil einfach auch mittlerweile sich in der ersten Liga Klubs tummeln, die da eher überraschend sind, dann wird es halt auch irgendwie eng und dann rutschen einige runter, wie jetzt vor dieser Saison. Und dann ist es plötzlich so, dass man auch erwartet, dass die hochgehen. Also was hat denn bitte schön Schalke in der zweiten Liga zu suchen? Was hat Werder in der zweiten Liga zu suchen? Die sollen bitte schön wieder hochkommen. Vor der Saison gab es auch Aussagen hier vom benachbarten hessischen Club, der auch festgestellt hat, da geht der Bundesliga aber eine gewisse Strahlkraft nach Übersee verloren. Wenn hier plötzlich Fürth spielt und Bielefeld spielt und Bochum spielt, dann muss ich sagen, herzlich willkommen. Das nennt man Wettbewerb, ja. Also man hat hier keinen Closed Shop in der ersten Liga, sonst können wir auch die Super League in die erste Liga verfrachten. Das wollen ja die Traditionsfans auch nicht. Aber dass dann in solchen Clubs wie uns oder auch vielleicht Paderborn es abgesprochen wird, oder jetzt auch Fürth-Erstliga tauglich zu sein und dadurch bitte schön nichts verloren zu haben, das hat man auch im Aufstiegskampf immer wieder so gehört. Natürlich in den sozialen Medien, die eh gerne lauter sind, als es vonnöten ist. Aber ich finde das mitunter auch gering schätzend. Und wenn man sieht, dass Darmstadt in der Saison zwar jetzt die entscheidenden Spiele Federn hat lassen, aber doch 71 Tore geschossen hat, sehr ansehnlich gespielt hat, mit einem jungen Team, entwicklungsfähig, mit einem Patrick Pfeiffer in der Innenverteidigung, der höchstwahrscheinlich zu höheren Berufen ist und uns womöglich abhanden kommt, aber hier eine enorme Entwicklung genommen hat vom HSV 2 in drei Jahren zu einem der Top-Innen-Verteidiger der Liga, dann zeigt das auch, dass hier was geht und dass hier gut gearbeitet wird und dass ein sportlicher Leiter wie Carsten Wielmann eine super Arbeit macht und das Trainerteam mit Lieberknecht und Obetay Ju erst recht. Also da findet sich was, da gibt es Nischen, da gibt es Möglichkeiten zu begeistern und das ist auch das, was die zweite Liga ausmacht, dass mal so ein Klub deutlich an die erste Liga klopft, den viele überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm haben und die ihm deshalb so ein bisschen die Berechtigung anzuklopfen, absprechen. Aber ich finde, das ist so eine gewisse Hochnäsigkeit. Jetzt äußere ich es, weil ich mich da auch ein bisschen angegriffen fühle als Darmstadt-Fan, aber das trifft auch andere. Also wie ich sagte, Paderborn oder Fürth oder wer weiß, vielleicht auch dann wieder der KSC.
Heidenheim ja auch.
Heidenheim auch und deshalb geht mir das so ein bisschen auf den Zeiger, weil gerade auch viele Traditionsfans sagen, ja bitte schön die Traditionsklubs oben rein, aber dann haben wir halt so eine Superliga auf Bundesligaebene und was soll das? Also dieser Wettbewerbscharakter, der vielleicht in der ersten Liga nicht mehr so ausgeprägt ist, zumindest vorne, der ist halt nur in der zweiten Liga gegeben und deshalb ist das ein Appell, doch bitte die zweite Liga auch ernst zu nehmen und nicht zu sagen, hat er nichts verloren, eine Etage höher. Und das ist mir so jetzt aufgefallen, hat sich so über die Saison ein bisschen aufgebaut und fiel am Anfang auch schon auf mit der besten zweiten Liga, wo viele traditionelle Zweitliga-Klubs einfach gar nicht vorkamen in der Erzählung. Und dennoch stimme ich auch den beiden anderen zu. Also es war eine emotionale Saison, die Fans kehrten zurück, es war ein enger Fight nach vorne hin, wo immer wieder unterschiedliche Konstellationen von Spieltag zu Spieltag waren und insofern hat die zweite Liga wirklich Unterhaltungspotenzial. Also nicht durchweg, aber in sehr vielen Fällen. Und deshalb, ja, Tschüss HSV und Tschüss Werder. Aber das war Liga 2, das ist kein Durchmarsch, das ist auch nicht nur kämpfen und beißen, sondern da ist auch durchaus ein gepflegter Ball am Start.
Eigentlich will ich die Liga auch gar nicht verlassen.
So habe ich zwischendurch auch gedacht, gar keine Lust so gegen Bayern, Leipzig zu spielen. Das muss eigentlich nicht sein, Hoffenheim, nee.
Ja, aber weil man mehr gewonnen hat oder wegen anderer Aspekte der 2.
Ja klar, das gehört mit dazu, dass man einfach, man hat in der 1. Liga jahrelang wie ständig auf die Schnauze gekriegt und jetzt kommt man einfach mal oder geht mit einem positiven Gefühl ins Stadion. Das ist schon netter, aber auch insgesamt so. Es ist viel kuscheliger. Man sieht mal ein paar neue Menschen und man fährt nicht das 10. Jahr hintereinander nach Augsburg oder Mainz oder sonstiges. Also nichts gegen Augsburg oder Mainz. Beim besten Willen nicht. Die sind sehr nett. Ich bin da bei dir.
Ich kann dich total auf der Knie.
Aber dann lernt man halt Heidenheim kennen oder Sandhausen, wo du richtig herzlich empfangen wirst. Und das ist dann auch wirklich schön. Ja, und wo auch gute Arbeit gemacht wird.
Also Max, du wirst ja auch als Begleiter der 1. Liga kennen. Welche Vereine haben es denn, um mal so diese Close-Job, erste Liga aufzumachen, nochmal, wie viele Vereine haben es in den letzten zehn Jahren geschafft, sich in der ersten Liga zu etablieren? Ja, Augsburg und Berlin, oder? Also Augsburg schon von vor zehn Jahren. Die sind jetzt, glaube ich, dann zum zwölften Mal oder dreizehnten Mal dabei. Aber außer Union hat es ja keiner geschafft, sich da zu etablieren. Wenn, dann gehen viele Klubs nach der zweiten oder dritten Saison wieder runter. Oder es gibt dann so Fahrstuhlklubs wie Stuttgart oder Köln, die dann immer wieder auch oben reinstechen können. Aber es ist doch ziemlich abgeschottet. Und durch diese Relegation hat man streng genommen ja dem Zooligisten einen Aufstiegsplatz weggenommen. Weil es haben, glaube ich, seit dieser Wiedereinführung erst drei Clubs geschafft. Ganz am Anfang Nürnberg, dann, glaube ich, Düsseldorf. Sina hatte das Spiel uns in Erinnerung gerufen. Und zuletzt auch Union. Ansonsten war immer der erste Ligist, und der konnte noch so schlecht spielen. Derjenige, der sich durchgesetzt hat. Und insofern gibt es eigentlich nur noch zwei Absteiger und zwei Aufsteiger. Und das ist dann doch so eine gewisse Besitzernswahrung.
Klar. Aber ich glaube, da kommt ja auch so ein bisschen das her, was du beschrieben hast. Weil zu den, also es haben sich Augsburg und Union haben sich etabliert und Mainz in der ersten Liga. Und dann kommen ja noch zwei Teams mit dazu, die man aber aus gewissen Gründen nicht nennt, nämlich Hoffenheim und Leipzig. Aber das sind ja, wenn man das einfach ganz normal betrachtet, sind das fünf Plätze, die in der ersten Liga für andere Teams nicht da waren. Deshalb hat das andere rausgedrängt. Und ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr die Zeit habt, können wir auch noch kurz über Relegation zur dritten Liga sprechen. Wir haben jetzt leider den Abstiegskampf komplett ausgeklammert bisher in dieser Sendung. Aber gewisse Mannschaften sind verschwunden. Und ich glaube, was du gesagt hast, Matthias, da muss man eine Unterscheidung machen. Ich glaube, sportlich gesehen habe ich das zumindest jetzt nicht so wahrgenommen, dass Bielefeld, Fürth oder auch Darmstadt sportlich gesehen, das abgesprochen werden würde, dass man es nicht verdient hätte, aufzusteigen oder nicht gute Arbeit machen würde. Ich glaube, es geht dann eher um weiche Faktoren, die dann auch sehr subjektiv sind. Deswegen gibt es da quasi jede Diskussion darüber, ist sehr vom Standpunkt des Diskutierenden abhängig. Aber zum Beispiel geht es halt um so Fragen wie überregionales Interesse, wie Zuschauerschnitt. Und da gibt es dann einen Unterschied. Also wenn ich mir jetzt den Zuschauerschnitt dieser zweiten Liga angucke, Quelle ist jetzt transfermarkt.de, dann ist auf Platz 1 Schalke mit 33.000, Platz 2 Werder mit 29.000, Platz 3 HSV 23.000, Nürnberg auch 23.000, St. Pauli 18.000, Düsseldorf, Rostock, Dresden und so weiter. Und Darmstadt kommt dann, da ist jetzt natürlich auch Corona mit dabei.
Und der Stadion-Umbau in erster Linie. Also wir haben gar nicht die Auslastung.
Genau. Und ich will jetzt auch gar nicht sagen, hey, Zuschauer, Auslastung soll alleine darüber entscheiden, wie man einen Verein bewertet und auch welche Bedeutung er für eine Liga hat. Aber ich glaube, das kommt halt bei so was mit rein. Und meinem Gefühl nach leiden Vereine wie zum Beispiel Darmstadt unter dieser Erstligasituation mehr als die Vereine, die auf- und absteigen. Weil sie eben noch mehr marginalisiert werden eigentlich. Das konnte man auch mit Unionerinnen und Unionern sehr gut besprechen, die einfach so lange in der 2. Liga waren und die einfach dieses Kommen und Gehen gesehen haben. Da kommt halt von oben, fällt ein 1. FC Nürnberg runter und dann geht er wieder rauf. Und irgendwann ist Nürnberg dann aber so runtergefallen und der Platz wurde so eng in der 1. Liga, dass die nicht mehr rauf gekommen sind. Ich meine, das ist ja auch eine Geschichte. Und davon hast du zwei, drei Vereine. Und solche Mannschaften wie Kaiserslautern zum Beispiel sind noch tiefer gefallen und haben ganz andere Probleme. Dresden ja letztlich auch, Rostock gehörte auch mit dazu. Also das sind so ineinander verwobene Diskussionen, wo dann auch manchmal subjektive Dinge mit reinkommen. Deswegen macht es auch manchmal, also in manchen Foren ist es dann auch schwierig, darüber zu diskutieren. Und gleichzeitig gibt es da auch keine Lösung. Weil natürlich kann nur das Sportliche darüber entscheiden, wie der aufsteigt. Und jeder, der aufsteigt, der hat es dann auch verdient. Also egal, wie die Relegation es läuft, der HSV hätte den Aufstieg definitiv verdient. Da wird niemand sich beschweren. Und so wäre es aber bei Darmstadt auch. Aber es gibt ebenso Nebenfaktoren. Und die prägen, glaube ich, wie wir über Ligen reden. Und der Unmut, den viele über die erste Liga haben, der zeigt sich dann auch in der Glorifizierung der zweiten Liga. Denn ich finde, das gehört zur Wahrheit auch mit dazu. Ich habe viel mehr zweite Liga gesehen in diesem Jahr als sonst. Ich habe auch an einem Spieltag mal alle Spiele gesehen, weil ich mich vorbereitet habe für einen anderen Podcast. Und nur sportlich gesehen, so geil ist die zweite Liga dann auch nicht. Tut mir leid. Also ich verstehe die ganze Folklore. Und dass es spannend war und so weiter, das sehe ich schon auch. Aber sportlich gesehen, boah.
Ja, ich denke, es gibt schon Teams, die es verdienen, genannt zu werden, wenn es darum geht, einen guten Ball zu spielen. Also Nürnberg oder auch gestern Paderborn. Das 3 zu 0, finde ich, täuscht über deren Leistungsfähigkeit hinweg. Die hatten auch sehr gute Offensivaktionen und können den Ball gut laufen lassen, zirkulieren lassen, spielen sich Chancen aus, haben Tempo drin. Also natürlich ist die Masse der Spiele jetzt nicht Deluxe, keine Frage. Aber ich finde, da gibt es schon auch Mannschaften, die nicht nur Langholz auspacken, sondern die schon auch spielerische Ansätze wählen und da ihr Mittel drin sehen. Und ich hatte auch vor der Saison mal den Thorsten Lieberknecht gefragt und während der Saison auch den Co-Trainer, ob sie denn eigentlich lieber Fehler erzwingen oder Fehler vermeiden wollen. Und beide haben gesagt, lieber Fehler erzwingen. Also es zeigt, dass es ein proaktiver Ansatz in ein Spiel zu gehen und nicht abzuwarten. Wie gesagt, trifft wahrscheinlich nicht auf die Masse der Spiele und der Teams zu, aber es gibt durchaus Teams, die da zu überraschend wissen. Auch der KSC zählt punktuell dazu, St. Pauli. Aber was du gemeint hast, stimmt natürlich auch, nur die Strahlkraft der Teams ist natürlich eine ganz andere. Wenn jetzt Werder und Schalke und HSV in der 2. Liga spielen, dann schaut man halt doch eher mal hin, als wenn es jetzt nicht diese großen Teams sind. Und auch ich als 2. Liga-Club denke mir, ja cool, Braunschweig geht hoch, das ist schon mal ein zu kräftiger Verein. Dann ist auch noch Magdeburg dabei mit einer fantastischen Fanszene. Wenn jetzt dafür Wiesbaden hochkäme, fände ich es vielleicht auch weniger cool. Muss ich auch gestehen. Also die fehlende Strahlkraft von Darmstadt, die ist ein Thema, keine Frage. Und wenn halt das Stadion dann im Endausbau nur 19.000 Fans Platz bietet, dann bist du in der Zuschauerrangliste natürlich nie weit vorne. Und auch wenn das Stadion 30.000 Fassungsvermögen hätte, wäre es dann aber auch nie voll. Das muss man auch sagen, klare Sache. Dennoch glaube ich diese Konstellation, dass die erste Liga so ein Stück weit entrückt und immer weniger Zugangsmöglichkeiten bietet, ist natürlich ein Faktor. Und dass man dann, wenn große runterkommen, eher die als diejenigen, die es zu beachten gilt, erwähnt, liegt natürlich dann auch in der Natur der Dinge.
Ich glaube auch, dass insgesamt der Unterschied zwischen 1. und 2. Liga ist gewachsen, aber auch der Unterschied zwischen 2. und 3. Liga. Also wir hatten lange Zeit immer mal wieder diese Durchmärsche. Ich meine, Darmstadt hat es ja auch gemacht, dass die dann einfach von der 3. Liga durch in die 1. Liga marschiert sind. Paderborn hat das mal geschafft und so weiter und so fort. Und das gibt es halt auch nicht mehr. Also die Neulinge, die jetzt aus der 3. Liga hochkommen, die müssen haben, auch schon stärker zu kämpfen. Also die 2. Liga ist schon besser geworden an sich, auch spielerisch. Das, was Matthias auch gerade schon gesagt hat, dass viel mehr Mannschaften mittlerweile versuchen, auch in der 2. Liga Fußball zu spielen. Aber wir haben es zum Beispiel dann im Pokal gemerkt, wir waren da zum Beispiel immer so diese Millisekunde langsamer als Freiburg und deswegen hatten wir überhaupt keine Chance gegen Freiburg letztlich. Und das ist dann halt so dieser Leistungsunterschied. Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wie schnell man den dann auch tatsächlich wieder gut machen kann. Also dass man halt tatsächlich Spieler hatte, die eben doch diese Millisekunde schneller sind. Das ist echt schwierig. Also ich glaube, diese Klappe wird auch eher weiter aufgehen, als dass sie sich so schnell schließen wird.
Ja und Geschwindigkeit ist wirklich, wenn ich das jetzt mal so vergleiche, ich gucke ja alle Spiele der ersten Liga und habe jetzt viele der zweiten Liga gesehen und habe auch ein paar der dritten Liga gesehen. Geschwindigkeit und Präzision im Passspiel, das sind die zwei Faktoren, an denen sich es verändert. Ansonsten, da sind also beim Passspiel auch die Unterschiede nicht mehr so krass wie früher noch. Aber tatsächlich Handlungsschnelligkeit ist das Thema. Ich habe zum Beispiel das Spiel gesehen, Lautern gegen Saarbrücken, was vom emotionalen Her und vom Spielverlauf her ein Wahnsinn war. Absoluter Wahnsinn. Aber rein sportlich gesehen waren sogar die Tore so albern. Also das war so, dass ich... Also sowas siehst du zum Beispiel in der Frauenbundesliga nicht. Da sind die technisch und handlungsschneller, da sind die viel, viel besser. Da fallen solche Tore nicht mehr. Und das hat mich so erstaunt, weil ich in die dritte Liga am seltensten gucke und da wenigstens mitbekomme. Und ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, Lautern, Zerbrücken, ihr spielt beide um den Ausstieg, super volle Hütte und ihr habt ja auch gute Spieler. Aber da fand ich auch den Unterschied so krass. Deswegen bin ich auch sehr gespannt auf die Relegation zwischen Dresden und Lautern neben allen Themen, die man da aufmachen kann. Aber mit dem Trainerwechsel jetzt auch noch zu Dirk Schuster bei Lautern, ob man diesen krassen Unterschied jetzt auch in der Relegation sehen kann. Ich meine, mich nämlich zu erinnern, dass das in der 2. und 3. Liga-Relegation schon häufiger so war, auch wenn es da auch hin und wieder mal die 3. Liga-Mannschaft geschafft hat, sich durchzusetzen. Aber dass da der Unterschied noch krasser war als zwischen 1. und 2. Liga.
Eigentlich sind die Relegationsspiele meistens ziemlich knapp, also zwischen 2.
Ja, also wenn wir uns vor zwei Jahren erinnern, müsste es gewesen sein, als Nürnberg gegen Ingolstadt mit dem letzten Angriff erst den Klassenerhalt sicher macht. Das fand ich schon ziemlich knapp und spannend. Da hatte ich jetzt nicht so den Klassenunterschied vor Augen wie jetzt bei den anderen, sprich 1. und 2. Liga. Wolfsburg war ja zweimal in Folge in der Relegation und hatte ja echt nicht gut gespielt in der Bundesliga und hat sich dennoch gegen Braunschweig beispielsweise damals durchgesetzt. Und das zweite Mal weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr. Aber das zeigt dann doch, dass vielleicht in einzelnen Situationen es reicht, ein Spiel zu entscheiden. Das, was du mit Handlungsschnelligkeit meinst, auch im Kopf allen voran. Das ist glaube ich wirklich ein Faktor, der ein 1. Liga-Team nochmal von einem 2. Liga-Team abhebt.
Ja, doch, ihr habt glaube ich recht. Ich habe da glaube ich eine schiefe Erinnerung. Also zwischen 1. und 2. Liga sieht man es sehr deutlich. Aber 2., 3. Liga. Na gut, wir werden es ja jetzt auch sehen. Dresden gegen Lautern, das ist ja auch noch.
Also es wird wirklich spannend, zwei emotionale Fans zu sehen, beide Lechzen danach in der 2. Liga zu bleiben oder hoch zu gehen. Und Jörg Schuster weiß ja, wie Relegation geht mit uns gegen Bielefeld. Die Älteren werden sich erinnern. Ich glaube schon, dass er den Kopf freikriegen kann bei den Lauternspielern, die ja jetzt wirklich die letzten drei Spiele ziemlich dahin gehen lassen. Wird spannend. Also alles andere als ein Selbstläufer für Dresden, die jetzt gestern auch noch gegen Abo verlieren. Ich glaube, da ist auch der Baumann brennend. Puh, wird hoffentlich nicht krachen und schon gar nicht auf den Rängen. Aber es wird emotional.
Ja, emotional wird es definitiv. Sina, du warst jetzt ein bisschen aus dem Vorschlag auch ein bisschen an der Aufnahmesituation. Gibt es noch irgendetwas, was du noch loswerden möchtest? Ich möchte nicht, dass du das Gefühl hast, ich hätte doch noch gerne 13 Sachen zu dieser Zweitliga-Saison gesagt.
Nee, alles gut. Also ich freue mich auf jeden Fall jetzt auch auf die Relegation und werde mir das dann gemütlich angucken und freue mich dann, wenn der HSV es tatsächlich schafft. Also ich hätte lieber den HSV, glaube ich, mit oben als Hertha. Aber ansonsten, ich bin einfach glücklich und schwebe auf meiner Glückswolke genau vor mich hin.
Gut, dann lassen wir dich auf deiner Glückswolke und wir wünschen Tanja, dass sie auf ihrer Glückswolke sitzen wird und dass es nicht zu Nerven aufreiben wird, Tanja. Die Relegation. Geht der Puls jetzt schon hoch wahrscheinlich, wenn du daran denkst?
Auch eigentlich, wir können ja nur gewinnen. Also für Berlin geht es darum, Status Quo zu erhalten. Wir können hingegen aufsteigen, also ich finde das super. Gut. Das ist viel entspannter als umgekehrt, wenn man rechts hinter ist und die Relegation muss.
Ja, die Relegation. Sie ist ein seltsames Phänomen, aber gut, inzwischen gewöhnt man sich fast schon wieder dran. Ja, warum bloß, ja stimmt. Ich habe erst reagiert und dann nachgedacht. Und dann fiel mir Karlsruhe und Fürth ein. Die hätten da nämlich eine andere Meinung zu. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich, dass ihr mit mir nicht nur auf diesen Spieltag, sondern auch ein bisschen auf die komplette Saison zurückgeblickt habt. Auch nochmal stellvertretend Dank an alle Gäste, die mit dabei waren im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Danke an Matthias Kneifl von hoch und weit, vom Kickshoe-Block. Als at Kickshoe-Block kann man dir auch auf Twitter folgen. Ich empfehle dir das sehr. Danke dir, lieber Matthias, auch dass du mir in Hinsicht auf die ewige Tabelle der 2. Männer Bundesliga die Augen geöffnet hast.
Ich ja sehr gerne und immer wieder gerne deinem Ruf zu folgen.
Ja, das wird ja dann auch der nächsten Saison im Kurzpass wieder der Fall sein. In der Schlusskonferenz dagegen werde ich hoffentlich dann Sina mal begrüßen dürfen vom Weserfunk, natürlich auch sehr herzlich empfohlen an dieser Stelle, et-SinaSophie, auf Twitter werde ich verlinken in den Show notes. Danke dir, liebe Sina, dass du trotz der stimmlichen Belastung diese Aufnahme auf dich genommen hast. Ja, sehr gerne. Und dann drücken wir Tanja Hufschmidt die Daumen vom HSV-Talk, den ich auch sehr empfehlen möchte, und natürlich friffedfschmidt77 auf Twitter. Danke dir, liebe Tanja. Ich wünsche dir dann möglichst viel Spaß bei den kommenden Spielen, dass du es als Spaß begreifen kannst. So hat es ja auch Werle von Stuttgart gesagt. Relegation kann auch Spaß machen. Vielleicht wird es der HSV beweisen.
Ja, ich danke für die Einladung.
Dann euch lieben Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Wie das geht, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Hier im Kurzpass-Feed wird hoffentlich in der nächsten Woche noch ein Rückblick auf die europäischen Top-League kommen. Und im Schlusskonferenz-Feed werdet ihr den Rasenfunk-Royal hören können ab dem 25. Mai. Der große Saisonrückblick auf die 1. Bundesliga der Männer. In diesem Sinne, habt eine gute Zeit, bleibt gesund und hoffentlich hören wir uns dann bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao!